mission impossible fallout
il ne peut y avoir de paix sont d'abord
une grande souffrance
plus la souffrance est grande plus la
peur est grande la fin que vous avez
toujours redouté mais c'est vous qui
allez morts sur la conscience
j'ai prié pour que ce ne soit pas vrai
salomone l'aisne s'est évadé à paris
et maintenant le monde est en danger
c'est la mission de la cia nous utiliser
un scalpel
je préfère un marteau
c'est pas une bonne idée c'est parce
qu'on dit à chaque fois honnêtement
il n'est pas là que pour observer c'est
un tueur gelé confiance quand vous trois
si vous dérapez il est autorisé à vous
tuer ce sont les ordres
sans rancune
tu es ou benji bon à gauche
salema dit mais qu'est ce que tu attends
je sente du haut d'un immeuble à paris
bonne chance
quand le vent va tourner et tout perdre
à tous ceux qu'il a aimés
tu ne sais pas pourquoi tu t'es engagé
tu ferais mieux de temps d'aller
s'il te plaît à dubaï comme toi toi
ça nous ressemble par étapes
peut-être qu'il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
accepter le retail ce qui est fait est
fait ses camions
c'est terminé quand nous décidons que
c'est terminé c'est parti
[Musique]
dition impossible fort là où cinéma le
1er août